welcome to cbs this morning we're going
to begin with america taking time
to honor the life and the legacy of
justice ruth bader ginsburg
in just a few hours her casket will
arrive at the supreme court building for
a private ceremony and after that
the public will be invited to pay its
respects in the senate chamber nearby
the angry debate over replacing ginsburg
ran
late into the night democrats are using
every tool they have
to slow down a republican march to
confirm
president trump's future nominee to fill
that seat on the high court
nancy cordes is on capitol hill nancy
where do things stand now
well the biggest development anthony is
that we now know that republicans appear
to have the votes to move forward
with this nomination some of them want
to wait to hold a final confirmation
vote until after the presidential
election
but the more vocal among them want to
act now
arguing that it reduces the risk of any
unforeseen snags
democrats say they're not giving up yet
this vacancy caused by the unfortunate
death of rbg
would lock in this hard right agenda
for a generation for a generation
senate democrats took to the floor for
more than five hours last night to lay
out what they say is at stake for the
country
let me be clear the future of roe v
wade is on the line the future of a
woman
being able to control her own body is on
the line
but in the midst of a global pandemic
with more than
200 000 of our loved ones
dead from a virus raging out of control
mitch mcconnell and senate republicans
want to install a justice
who will rip that health care away
earlier they delayed senate business
one of the few procedural tools in their
arsenal if republicans say they have the
votes
is there anything you can do we have to
go out and mount a case
that this country is going to be
fundamentally changed by this
nominee the only thing republicans seem
to be split on is whether to hold a
confirmation vote
before the election or after i hope it
happens before the election some people
feel like it energizes
the republican base i think i don't
think there's any doubt about that
senate leader mitch mcconnell
would only say he's committed to a vote
this year
early polls show that a majority of
americans disagree with your approach
they want you to wait
does that give you pause well as all of
us have pointed out we have an
obligation under the constitution
should we choose to take advantage of it
with a
president of the same party as the
senate to advance the nomination
the president plans to make that
nomination on saturday
and now we're going to pick a great
woman
cbs news has learned that judge amy
coney barrett was
at the white house for a second time on
tuesday
she is a favorite of religious
conservatives who believe that she will
help to overturn
roe versus wade and while the president
is considering
other judges aides here on capitol hill
tell us that gop
leaders favor amy coney barrett because
she's a known quantity and has already
endured
one tough nomination fight back in 2017
for her federal appeals court post tony
all right nancy thank you very much